hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
welcome to the unboxing of the Nexus 6
plus
just kidding it's the Nexus 9 so there's
no more Nexus 7 and there's no more
Nexus 10 but there's this new 9 inch
tablet somewhere in the middle now
people have seen this already I'm
actually going to be showing you guys
the white one instead of the dark one
everyone's seen the dark one if you like
so I'm going to giving my first
impressions of it and as a least a
slightly more interesting box and the
Nexus 6 did the Nexus 6 had this all
blank box like the printer ran out of
ink a little bit of an interesting look
same as the iPhone 6 but we actually do
need a knife to cut this box for the
first time basically there are opinions
about this device out there already
there are a lot of mixed opinions and
there are some reviews out already
people have already seen this device in
the wild and it's got some really
interesting critiques because well first
of all there was a software update
recently that came out for it and a lot
of those reviews went out I guess before
the software update because they had
review units but this is going to be my
honest first impressions of using this
little tablet for the first time and I'm
someone who's used similar tablets like
that so this is it this is the white
Nexus 9 but I'm going to first of all
let's just take this a plastic off as we
do in all our reviews and it does look
again very similar to that Nexus 5 so if
you've seen my Nexus 5 videos you see
the little protruding flash up here in
the camera and that white look it says
Nexus sideways but overall I think it
looks pretty cool but let's place this
aside just for one second while we get
to whatever else is in the packaging so
blue Nexus packaging this time Nexus 6
if you saw that video yesterday was red
and we get of course a little bit of
warranty information no sim since this
is a Wi-Fi only tablet but if you get
the LTE version I wonder if you get a
SIM card ejector tool and then since
this is made by HTC you have your HTC
made accessories so that would be your
charging brick and your power adapter
pretty simple stuff but I'm going to put
that right back away because I want to
take a look at the tablet again there
has been a lot of talk about the way
this thing is built so it's now a 4 by 3
tablet first of all reminding me a lot
of the iPad Mini and it's a lot bigger
because it has much larger display but
again very different between these two
devices same camera placement similar
button placement but a little bit
different than that also I said this is
going to be the white version but I
might as well show you guys the dark
version of the nexus 9 to the both feel
very similar they have this soft touch
feel but it's very similar again to the
nexus 5 of last year where the dark is a
little bit softer touch than a light
because if the light was made of the
same soft touch material as a dark it
would stain more easily and even though
you aren't necessarily putting this
thing in your pocket you will notice a
difference in color so it's a little bit
of a different feel
I know only notice that if you have the
two side-by-side but I'm going to go
ahead and boot this thing up yes you do
have a metal band around the side which
is pretty cool and that definitely
influences the way it feels in the hand
and I'd say even feels more premium than
it did before
and it's running Android 5.0 lollipop so
this is my first look at lollipop on a
tablet at least because I haven't gotten
the update yet on my Nexus 10 so I'm
going to go to change angles here and
get this thing set up and take a deep
dive into what looks like a new OS for
me all right two things I've already
noticed since startup number one when I
was putting in my Wi-Fi password and
just using the keyboard the tactile
feedback just from the vibration motor
in here felt really chill really nice
and probably a lot better than any other
tablet I've ever used period and number
two here's our update this is a 297
point 2 megabyte update right off the
bat from taking it out the box so let's
do it
so here we have it this is our first
look at Android 5.0 on the Nexus 9 now
again while I was setting it up I was
just messing around with it seeing how
it feels in the hand it's obviously not
going to be a one-handed tablet with a 9
inch screen but if you have big enough
hands I mean this is a lightweight thing
anyway so it's not that unwieldly to
hold and flail around I guess high
resolution display it's it's a little
bit squishy on the back
maybe not squishy but it does have a
little bit of give and some other people
have shown this before maybe not talked
about it in depth that much in their
reviews but it's definitely a little bit
there as its built really different from
any metal tablet you've seen and these
buttons are very shallow I wish they
were a little more tactile but I clicked
that power button you swipe right in of
course these big front-facing speakers
are going to give me some awesome audio
I'll let you know how they sound
compared to other things like the
boomsound speakers of the One m8 and
others but essentially we're going to
see how this compares to the Nexus 6 and
other tablets I'm going to open up a
couple of apps here because I didn't
actually do that on the Nexus 6 video
which if you haven't seen that yet you
can check that out the calendar looks
pretty well it looks different from the
previous generation app open gmail 5.0
because that's also different you can
see this looks super different from the
way it looked before I do have inbox but
I feel like I've started using Gmail
again more just because I like having a
little bit more control you have Google
Play Music again you have all these new
icons a lot of people have talked about
this being a sort of a blown-up version
of the phone interface and a lot of the
things you do see here will remind you
of the Android 5.0 experience on your
phone except for one they use multiple
columns but overall here I'm enjoying
the experience because I happen to be a
fan of the way stock Android looks and
feels other than that I am game to talk
about just about anything that people
have seen in other review videos you
might have watched other videos and
reviews about that if you have any
clarifications you want to ask about
there I'm game to talk about that if you
have any other curiosities about other
things with this tablet I'm game to talk
about that too I'll check out the
calendar just so we can see that
color-changing background again pretty
neat even though it's not exactly a late
hour what else Google fit a lot of the
stuff is going to ask me to sign in
because this is a
brand-new account but yeah you'll see
this is this is very lollipop --is--
with all the animations and things all
over the place multitasking google now
it's all here it's all going to be
reviewed and it's just my first
impressions of the device so if you're
free to leave a thumbs up if you enjoyed
again lots more videos coming in
November hope you enjoyed this one and
I'll talk to you guys in the next one
peace